hello and welcome today's live webinar
using data to drive automated screening
and effective reporting I'm Robert
Castellanos of elaborate and I'll be
moderating for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinth believing scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars events in
scientific collaboration and learning it
is also sponsored by beckman coulter
assessment Coulter we are dedicated to
advancing and optimizing the laboratory
for more than 80 years we have been a
trusted partner for laboratory
professionals helping to advance
scientific research and patient care we
have a vital role our focus on
innovation reliability and efficiency
had led us to become a partner of choice
for clinical research and industrial
customers around the globe for more
information please visit Beckman com
let's get started you can pose questions
to the speaker during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them in the Q&A box which
will open when you click the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slightly no click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems hearing this
presentation just click on the support
button found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left this is an
education webinar and this awesome free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the C
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I'd
like to now introduce you to today's
speakers tim shell and dr. Mike Kowalsky
Tim is
fast systems engineer and the integrated
solutions group of beckman coulter life
sciences he's received his degree in
computer science from old homeland
institute of technology tim has spent
his career with beckman coulter and the
areas of software research and
development custom engineering services
build project management and life
science automation this projects has
focused in the areas of automated data
processing and last year a new version
of Beth Ann Coulter's data management
project start dr. Mike Kowalski is a
staff application scientist and the
sample preparation and applied markets
group of beckman coulter alive scientist
he received his PhD in microbiology and
molecular genetics from Harvard
University prior to joining Beckman
month was a postdoctoral fellow Novartis
Institute for biomedical research for a
used automation to screen for normal
regulatory a stem cells per riffin singh
and differentiation since joining
Beckman might have developed automated
applications and the areas of stroke
ultra cellular analysis and mass
spectrometry I would like to now hand it
over to today's presenters well welcome
we're very excited to be here giving you
this webinar and today we'd like to talk
about using data to drive automated
screening and effective reporting today
we're going to take a look at how to
create a data management plan and the
components that go into that and then
Mike's going to cover information about
how he put together a data management
plan for a specific screen for cancer
regulators as we look at a data
management plan this is a little
different than a data plan on your phone
this is something where you want to be
looking at planning out how your data
flows through a system and data means a
lot of different things there's
different layers different types there's
different ways of looking at things and
it means a lot of different things to
different people so today we're going to
take a look at how we can organize data
in a way that is more meaningful and
that can drive results through your
assay today we'll follow a process
a workflow where you're importing data
in the beginning using data to drive
your process and then look at some
analysis and we'll come back to this
workflow several times as we move
through the presentation let's first
look at the types of data in the lab for
instance there's method and run data lab
where properties and well properties
will go through these all in more detail
then we'll look at a taxonomy of data
what as as it applies to an instrument
such as the biomech automated pipetter
is shown here this is where data comes
into the system and influences it in
order to produce results that you can
work with we'll discuss three data
management tools that we use a beckman
coulter to perform automated workflows
that process both your samples and your
data together and then finally we'll
look at the data workflow cycle import
process and analyze so we'll be also
using as Tim mentioned an example of a
micro RNA screen as a way to show and
demonstrate how the data moves through
an automated system a little more
background on the screen the goal was to
identify micro RNAs that can affect
either cancer cell growth or
chemosensitivity to chemotherapeutics
the approach we took in brief was to
transfect colon carcinoma cell line
hct116 with a micro RNA mimic library
and following transfection we would
treat the cells with 5-fluorouracil a
common chemotherapeutic agent for colon
carcinoma we would then count total
cells and dead cells as measured by drag
seven uptake drag seven being a
fluorescent reagent that is unable to
penetrate normal cells but can penetrate
through damaged cell membranes and we
would a sadie cells at multiple time
points to gain a greater understanding
of what's occurring in the system and
we'll go through this in a bit more
detail more on the specific workflow so
the micro RNA library which we purchased
from sigma arrived in 24 96-well plates
to both conserve reagents as well as
conserve space on the deck and in the
storage areas weary consolidated these
into six
384 will place after rehydrating the
libraries during the actual screen those
library place were then diluted into
media and transfected added with a
transfection lipid reagent in this case
darme effect 1 and this was all
occurring in black walled clear bottom
9th 384-well a safe place again since we
were going to use imaging for our
analysis these reagents were then
stamped into a replicate plates so we
now have 12 384 well plates again all of
the has a variety and fills were then
added to each of the 12 plates to begin
the transaction process after 24 hours
we added both my floor uracil to begin
the induction of apoptosis as well as
the drac seven reagent to look at the
immediate staining following
transfection with the micro RNAs we've
ended an immediate read at two different
wavelengths using the spectra max I 3x
with mini max imaging cytometer and we
looked on bright field to do a total
cell count and looked at 731 nanometers
to look at Drac 7 uptake and again
measuring is day one we are identifying
micrornas whose overexpression was
sufficient to induce cytotoxicity in
cells we then reanalyze it sells 24
hours later so now the cells have been
in the presence of 5-fluorouracil for 24
hours and here we would hope to identify
micrornas that could enhance the
toxicity of 5-fluorouracil we then ran
the analysis again at day 3 and now most
of the cells will have undergone
apoptosis due to 5-fluorouracil but we
might be able to identify micro RNAs
that could actually inhibit this process
and those micro RNAs could then be
future targets for chemo therapeutic
intervention so to give you an idea of
what this all translates to from a data
perspective obviously we started with 6
384-well library plates 384 wells each
with two replicant as they plates for
each well two wavelengths that we were
analyzing at three different time points
for a grand total of twenty-seven
thousand six hundred and forty eight
data points simply coming off the
analyzer and that needs to be Matt back
to our library this doesn't take into
account other pieces of data that will
be describing as we go through the
this is an image of the system that we
use to actually execute the screen again
is centered around the biomech fxp which
Tim mentioned earlier this has a
multi-channel and a spanning head
allowing us a lot of flexibility for our
liquid handling and since this is a cell
culture application we enclosed it in a
HEPA filtered enclosure to make sure
that the cells were maintained in a
sterile state during manipulation empty
plates and chips were brought from the
storage component on the left-hand side
and as cells were treated they were then
stored in the incubator on the
right-hand side the place were brought
in and off the system using a shuttle
and would pass through barcode readers
to identify the place as they moved on
and off the minimax shown on the left
hand side was also integrated with the
system and plates for them placed on the
minimax for analysis using the robotic
transport shown on the left again this
is all you can imagine a very
potentially complex system but the goal
here is to integrate as much as possible
so that minimizes the amount of user
interaction to help minimize the number
of mistakes that can be made in your
sample processing and the same is true
for the data we want to have that be as
integrated and as seamless as possible
so there's less chance to introduce
errors thanks for going through all of
that Mike I really do appreciate that
there are people like you that know all
the science stuff so that I can stay in
my comfort zone of the of the data but
really as we look at automation and as I
talk to customers who are looking to
automate their workflow we need to
automate both the sample processing and
and automate that a say that you've been
working hard on but if you haven't
brought the data through that process
then then you've only done half the job
it's really the data that comes out of
the system that's important so let's
take a look at the different types of
data that will be dealing with so I'll
walk through a hierarchy of three
different levels so first of all at the
highest level we have method data this
is something that's global to the run or
to the to the assay that's being
performed it's not specific or varying
from one plate to the next or from well
too well and but it is specific to what
what's happening on this day with this
particular assay so some examples of
method data from the screen could be
such things as the user
we have a login for the biomech you can
tell who's been using the system to run
which assays what's the name of the
method am I are currently running my
transfection protocol or one of my
analysis protocols what's the start time
so I mentioned it was 24 hours later
after I wanted after transfection that I
wanted to analyze but what did 24 hours
or was it really 21 or 27 or somewhere
there about was there anything
noteworthy that is worth making notes on
for a given process and although this
particular screen only had 12 total
plates you can imagine a much larger
screen such as one that would have a
hundred place you might want to process
them in ten batches of ten so you could
imagine something like a batch number
which would apply to all the plates that
went through and give and run one layer
further down we look at lab where data
this would be something that's specific
to one piece of lab where that's being
used in this automated run you can have
multiple layers or levels that are
assigned to that piece of lab where but
it will be will be distinct from one
piece of lab where to the next example
is from the screen the main one would be
the barcode this is really what was the
unique identifier for each plate and one
that would confirm the place identity as
it was brought out of storage or out of
the incubator but you can also imagine
other runs where you might just have
other identifiers such as a plate name
which you could give it or a given lab
where type is it a black wall to clear
bottom plate or is it round or flat
bottom as well as information such as
the storage position of the plate where
is it currently located in the system is
that in the incubator is it being
analyzed scrambling and how long has a
given plate been in or out of the
incubator you can certainly imagine that
if I forgot to put a box of tips in the
plate the plate would have been brought
out and then realized that there were no
tips present so it would be waiting for
me to fix the system this what
information could be tracked so if I did
see something abnormal for that given
place we would have that type of
information knowing that maybe it was
out of the incubator for a longer time
than the others the lowest level that
will go into today is talking about well
beta this is something that will vary
from one well to the next often it may
be caused an array of information but
it's it's about the wells on 11
microplate or 11 rack of tubes and again
multiple values / well would be allowed
as
can be many different characteristics
that are applied to an individual well
some examples from the screen obviously
the main ones of interest would be the
micro RNA that is present in a given
well or instead of given replicate wells
as well as the sequence of that micro
RNA additional information which might
be all the same across the plate but we
chose to label it as well information
because it could vary include such
things as the transfection lipid the
cell line that we're using the compounds
such as five floors so that we're
treating with and the volume present in
each well of each plate finally when it
comes to the analytical data obviously
the main results were interested in our
our total cell counts by at all the
different time points and our drag seven
counts at different time points so now
we've covered the first third of our
presentation looking at the different
hierarchy of data with method lab we're
in well data so if you do have any
questions take a moment to go ahead and
enter that question and we'll move on to
talk about three data management tools
so the first tool is sammie TX this is
one of our software's that we use when
it comes to processing batches of plates
essentially you want to run the same
process over and over on multiple place
Sam is created creating these types of
work clothes that will process a plate
through a variety of different
treatments and this helps you manage
those integrated resources that I
described earlier so again it won't
necessarily take a plane out of the
integrated incubator until it's ready to
be processed on the biomech this is also
great for scheduling actions as you can
see in the Gantt chart down below
basically Sammy is trying to process
samples as most efficiently as possible
but it needs to know where all the lab
where is at different times and how it
can be processed most efficiently so the
job that Sam EEx does from a data
perspective is it attaches data to
source plates it copies information from
source plate to a destination plate such
as when pipetting occurs it collects
analytical data from readers or other
instruments that produce data such as a
2d barcode reader and then attaches that
two plates as well data and then it also
can be driven through information that's
on libor or at the well level to effect
that the direction that automation takes
some
if some hit picking or some if statement
type functionality the next tool is dart
our data acquisition and reporting tool
and what this is it's an excellent data
repository and we'll describe a lot more
about how this works as the talk goes on
but what's nice is that it works either
with biomech or with Sammy or both
software's and one of the nice features
that I really enjoyed using was the fact
that it allows me to view data as it's
coming off live but I can view it
remotely so I don't necessarily have to
be at the system to watch data as it's
produced I can be doing this from my
laptop back at my desk but the job that
dart does from a data perspective is
collecting information from Sammy or
biomech method as soon as that
information is learned in the Sammy or
biomech software it's stored away in the
data repository if running multiple
methods on multiple days or on multiple
instruments dart is able to retrieve
that plate data so nothing needs to be
re-imported just simply reading the
barcode and loading the data returns any
information known about that plate so
now you can add additional layers of
information or make decisions based on
information that's in the repository and
finally information isn't trapped in
your database there's a flexible well
and web and Excel based reporting tool
that allows you to format the reports as
you wish or to drill down and to explore
the information through the web our
final piece of data management tool is
the Sami process management software and
what this can do is link sami methods /
days and weeks and this is really key
for those cell culture type of
applications that were describing today
obviously my screen took place over the
course of three active days and not
including the reformatting steps that
were done earlier but if you can
certainly imagine workflow that might
take eight to 14 days or you can imagine
a continuous cell culture type of
process which could go on for months and
sami can schedule the activities on a
calendar so you can see what resources
are needed as well as what actions are
going to take place on a given day if
all you're doing a row is running a
simple set of methods Sammy process
management does not bring a lot of value
but if you're running multiple processes
with multi
batches of plates it helps you to make
sure you're running the right method on
the right place at the right time it
also allows you to look at when your
system is available or when it has been
reserved so that you can plan out am I
able to start this on next wednesday
because the following friday we actually
need to take the system down for
maintenance can help you to make those
types of decisions so there we move
quickly through three data management
tools once again these are the tools
that Beckman Coulter uses for data
management that there are other tools on
the market available what we really want
to talk to you about is how to make a
data management plan that sets you up
for success so we'll move to the final
element of our discussion today talking
about the data workflow there are really
three purposes that data can serve in an
assay and one is around identification
the next is around process information
that either information coming in that
drives the process or information that
is discovered as part of the process
such as reading a barcode and then
finally there's analysis this is really
the goal and the purpose of running the
assay it's really not about moving
liquid or taking it to a reader it's
really about understanding the results
of that read and being able to draw
conclusions from it so here we have a
data management plan workflow it goes
through an import process through an
import step a processing step and an
analysis step and then once you've drawn
conclusions about your results that
almost always there's a follow-on step
another process that begins and that
might be downstream in another lab or it
might be yourself repeating results
confirming results or or retesting items
but this is the the data workflow so the
data workflow on our screen michael go
into here yep so sticking with the idea
of focusing on on importing data the
main piece of data we needed to import
was our library information so we did
receive a CSV file from the manufacturer
at Sigma basically indicating what micro
RNAs were present in which wells of the
original 24 or 96 well plates
as well as sequence information
accession numbers etc so we were able to
within the biomech software import that
information and applied to those
original 24-well plates and link it to
those barcodes when we actually executed
liquid handling steps for the
reformatting into the 384-well plates
that additional information was
transferred to those new place the new
384-well library place and that
information would then link to the bar
codes of those 384 old plates and stored
in the dart repository here's how this
would look like using our tool so in the
in the background we see the CSV file
that was provided by Sigma and we attach
it to the source plate in this case this
is the library plate which is in the
lower left of that of the of the
workflow that you see a snapshot of a
Sammy method this information is brought
into the system and then all of it we
can choose which columns of information
are attached to that plate and that
those columns can be brought in as
either lab or data or as well data so
basically what this looks like from the
data repository tool is as follows of
following this initial reformatting we
have shown in red the data that we've
imported again as dimension we only
chose to import the micro RNA ID and
micro RNA sequence and that is now the
well level data that's linked to the bar
code of the 384-well plate but shown
here in green eyes additional process
information that came out of that
initial run such as we mentioned before
the method name start and finish times
at the run level at the plate or lab
where level we have the bar code which
I've already mentioned as well as the
name and storage position of those
library place and at the well level we
actually have the updated volume
information for each well in the new
384-well library plates so moving
forward from that now that we have this
information there's additional processes
that the library place obviously undergo
so when the library is brought back onto
the system and the bar code is scanned
that additional information of the micro
RNAs access from the dart repository and
as we Tran
for the libraries to the assay plates
again once again that data is taken
forward throughout the process as well
as then brought back from the dart
repository during the replicate stamping
so that information is now present on
our 12 a safe place and when cells are
added that additional information gets
added as well so we first brought the
information on to the plate that was the
import step and so now we need to bring
that information through the system now
the information was all attached to the
library plate but we needed on the assay
plate there's really two ways to work
with correlation of data one is to get
your results and then work backwards
from the well transfers and go go to the
beginning of what what was transferred
through all of these plates but a much
simpler way to go is to first bring
bring the information on to the library
plate the target is to put it on the
assay plate so that we can have columns
side by side the analysis with micro RNA
ID and how does this get accomplished it
happens in a transfer note the biomech
and sammie software when we transfer
sample we also transfer data the
information about the sample from the
library played even though it's being
reformatted from 96 to 384 even though
it's being moved in to replicate plates
that information all will get
transferred into that destination later
on when we collect the analytical
information will now be able to put
those two pieces side by side so as to
mention this gives you an idea of what
the repository would have in it now
again we have brought that information
that we originally imported still shown
in red that has been brought forward to
the new essay plates and linked to the
bar code as well as updated information
from the process such as what lipid was
added and what cell line was added well
the rest and as well as having new
updated volumes for all the library and
assay plates so the next step in the
workflow is again to first add the
compounds the five glory are still in
the drac seven and then we begin the
acquisition of our analysis data so
and we get the minimax reads of two
different wavelengths at three different
time points on day 1 day 2 and day 3 so
how do we actually attach that data to
the lab where so Tim will explain this
in our Sammy method so here's a simple
Sammy method it's just linear take the
plate out get it to the to the reader
and then then store it back away in this
case we have two plates being run
through simultaneously that was just a
decision on how to most efficiently use
the system and there are two different
readers reader nodes in on each line the
first one is doing your cell count and
attaching that to the plate the second
read is the drac seven count and this is
then run at three different time points
so this method gets run three times and
produces in this case six different sets
of data so at the completion of the
screen when our data repository should
look like is basically very similar to
what we've seen previously but now shown
in purple is the analytical data that
has been added as to mention we have
three different time points with two
different wavelengths each and what you
can see is one of the benefits is that
we now have that because the data has
been brought forward we now have all of
the information we need to do a direct
comparison there's no need to backtrack
and try and figure out what micro RNA
corresponds to which analytical result
all of that information is friend
brought forward so it's all linked to
the assay plate by the barcode in
addition we now have also added some
more process information such as the
compound that's been added in this case
by flurry or so and once again all of
that information is present in one
location so we do not have to do any
additional backtracking the real value
of this is that we have now brought the
micro RNA IDs the sequence and put it
right next to the information on the
that we achieved from from the reader
looking at
process data this is a very important
piece of making a data management plan
just as you would look at what do I need
in my system to pipette pipette from one
plate to another do I need a dispenser
do I need a washer do I need some sort
of heater heating or cooling on my
system the same thing you should be
looking for is to make sure that your
data management needs are being
addressed through software so a couple
of things that the beckman coulter
software can offer are these are some of
the verbs that are available in the
system being able to create information
from from a text file or importing it
being able to copy or delete rename
information being able to do math on a
data set to do division addition
subtraction and load information from a
previous run all of these are verbs that
are accomplished through the beckman
coulter software and none of them
require any sort of database knowledge
or sequel queries none of them have any
sort of particular data container it's
just a natural workflow that just
integrates into your method and this is
the most important element of a data
management plan is to ensure that as you
move your sample that your data moves
along and that any new information is
attached to that plate or to the well in
an appropriate way the dart dart is the
key that that brings all of these pieces
together so the information can come in
from a handheld scanner or from an
import it can be incorporated from one
or more different automated systems it
can also be annotated or viewed from
remotely any device that can see the
dart database so this would be something
probably limited to inside your
enterprise environment can now browse
that dart data and view it likewise any
data producers such as a microplate
reader or a 2d barcode scanner can also
publish information into this system
dard is what is able to connect all this
information together and
once again if your data is trapped in a
system or if it's trapped in CSV files
on disk if it requires copying and
pasting in order to do anything manage
any sort of management with it then your
and your software system really isn't
doing all the jobs that it could be and
so you want a system that not only moves
that information through the system but
then gives you a good way to view it as
you as you perform your analysis in the
case of dart we have two different tools
that can operate on that data so the
first is a query builder and this allows
you to to choose the columns that you
want to see in a report on the left hand
side are all the different values the
run characteristics the lab where
properties and the well values that have
been captured as part of an automated
run and then on the right hand side
you're just selecting which columns you
want to see now the real value in dart
is that it's going to collect all of the
different values and store them so that
if you ever wish to come back and look
at new information it's available so
when you're performing your report you
don't need to clutter it with
information that you might need later
you just put the things you want to look
at and you have a nice concise view
about information in Excel and even
better once you're in Excel you have a
live link back to that database so as
you perform new runs or have more daily
operation you can have cascading charts
or other sheets that evaluate from this
from this from this named range of data
and as you add new information as you
run more information as you run more
samples through your system and more
informations available through the
spreadsheet so rather than producing a
new spreadsheet every day you're able to
just click the refresh button all that
information comes into the system all of
your charts and graphs update and you
can use the same tool one day to the
next get that get that spreadsheet
optimized for just the way that you like
to look at it so the other meal this is
through the web this is an example from
a laptop computer that could be viewing
this from from another room in the case
of
Mike system it's tucked away in an
applications lab and in a clean room and
so he goes up to go in there so if you'd
like to take a look at how things are
going he could use use this from his
desk out a cubicle and and be able to
drill down into it as we just kind of
look at some different pieces here we
can look at the different pieces of data
that we talked about earlier here's our
run data here's where we can drill down
into plate properties and then the large
view there the plate map shows the
different layers of well data and
there's a drop down where you can switch
between those or you can see them all in
columns to look at things side by side
and that allows for some real drill down
was this useful to you Mike as you were
going through it was there were a couple
times for example during just doing some
of the initial optimization experiments
rather than having to export things to
excel in really kind of compare things
here I was able to just look immediately
in the data browser to do an initial
correlation between results and micro
RNAs in my library and also during the
actual runs because we were running 12
different wreaths on a given day this
would extend over about a six and a half
hour time period so to have to sit there
and watch for six and a half hours to
make sure plates come out of our red two
different times certainly helps to have
the physical integration of the
instrument so I didn't have to sit there
and replace plates every 15 or 30
minutes but it also helps to be able to
remotely view the data to make sure that
everything's got running smoothly so
what is the actual with the actual
outcome of the screen now that we've
hopefully shown you how data was
processed throughout the the workflow
and how we were able to get everything
out into an Excel format I was then able
to look at my results and the way I
chose to do my analysis was to calculate
a percent toxicity in each well and I
achieved this by just dividing the dead
cell counts by the total cell counts and
rather than just looking at the drag
seven counts by themselves I thought
this gave me a better opportunity to
possibly normalize wells where due to
cell death you may have left total cells
so that may seem like an
underrepresented drak seven count but by
doing it for sin toxicity that would
hopefully be identified shown here is
just kind of two wells from a plate that
was 24 hours after trans
affection so again in this case it would
be prior to 5-fluorouracil or
simultaneous with 5-fluorouracil
addition so the effects here should only
be due to micro RNA transfection shown
in row a at the top is what was one of
the wells that achieve the plate mean so
basically the average response i saw on
that plate overall shown on the left is
the bright field image that allowed us
to count total sales and on the right
although it may be a little tough to see
you hopefully can see some red dots that
correspond to our Drac 7 staining and
shown below in row B you'll hopefully
notice they're significantly less cells
or the cells appear to be rounded up in
the bright field image and significantly
more red staining in the drag 7 analysis
and by calculating percent toxicity this
corresponds to about a three-fold
increase above the average level of
cytotoxicity I saw up in row a so this
would basically be what a hit looks like
at this given time point shown here is a
single plate out of the 12 SI plates we
ran and what we were looking for was
again basically trying to find some hits
that would be considered outliers
compared to the average response of
transfection conditions shown here is
one plate the 320 nan control wells from
a 48 hours post-transfection time point
so 24 hours after 5-fluorouracil
treatment and what you can see is that
on average the plate averaged out to
about seventeen percent or eighteen
percent toxicity for the well and what
we were looking for four hits was to
find some well that had more than two
standard deviations of a response away
from the plate mean so for this that
meant above 34% toxicity or below two
percent toxicity and for it to be
considered hit it has to be present in
both replicates so shown here there's
about 14 wells that you can see for this
particular place that was above the 34%
toxicity to Sigma threshold but the ones
that are marked in red are those nine
hits that actually were present in both
replicate wells for this for these
conditions so what it all come out to
well out of our 1920 micrornas that we
tested we came out with about 50 hits
for a hit rate of about 2.6
% these hits really broke down into
about half of them inducing rapid
toxicity unto themselves so over
expressing the micro RNA of 26 micro
RNAs was sufficient to induce
significant toxicity by itself remaining
24 are either those micro RNAs that can
enhance 5-fluorouracil toxicity or are
possibly just slowly inducing toxicity
and needed 48 or 72 hours to actually
show their effect but what's also
noteworthy is that we did not find any
significant inhibitors of toxicity and
that's not really unexpected when we saw
that again we would have to be achieving
below for example 2% toxicity at the 48
hour time point so possibly just due to
a result of our stringent conditions we
did not find any micro RNAs that seemed
to inhibit 5-fluorouracil induced
toxicity looking at the screens at a bit
more granularity of those 50 hits that
we identified 24 of them seemed to have
some known functions based on literature
of those 24 22 of them were shown to
have a role in as tumor suppressors and
this actually makes a lot of sense this
is what you would expect your phenotype
to be if you overexpress a micro RNA
that had a tumor suppressor role you
would expect to see increased toxicity
in a cancer cell line so 22 of our 24
known hits pretty much fell into what we
would expect the outcome to be we did
have two micro RNAs out of our 24 that
are identified as oncogenes and again
you would think if you overexpress this
micro RNA alone this would lead to
increased cell growth and so you would
possibly expect to see not something
that would come up as an increase in
toxicity however it was only these two
were only hits in the presence of
5-fluorouracil so one could certainly
expect that driving cell growth in the
presence of a chemotherapeutic that is
targeting rapidly dividing cells could
obviously potentially lead to increased
cytotoxicity so what this really means
is that either 22 are likely even 24 of
our known 24 micrornas that have a role
in cancer basically came out with the
expected outcome and this really
reflects is kind of a byproduct of
having
accurate micro RNA identification this
really ensures the fact that we did not
have some sort of mix-up in the middle
of the screen and we were misidentifying
our micrornas we did not really see any
results that seemed to fly in the face
of what we would expect so not only is
this basically a nice confirmation about
the value of bringing all that data
forward on the system but it actually
gives us a lot of confidence in our
remaining twenty six unknown hits so
these could potentially be legitimate
tumor suppressors or again other sorts
of compounds or other sorts of micro
RNAs that could enhance 5-fluorouracil
toxicity and so again because we have
the confidence in our data having been
brought forward we have the confidence
to go back and if we want to do some
validation and hip validation
experiments we know that we should not
have misidentified any of these and
possibly be missing some sort of real
needle in the haystack novel tumor
suppressor due to identifying the wrong
micro RNA from our screen so to
summarize kind of the screen aspects
from from the data components again as
we mentioned we have successfully
managed over 27,000 data points and
that's only counting the reader data
that's not counting the additional
process data that we discussed such as
time in and out of the incubator or cell
lines added etc and the benefit is that
automating the sample processing I think
we all typically that's sort of
forefront in our mind we see the value
because it takes us away from the bench
but the fact that the automation of the
data flow happens seamlessly and without
any additional work it really is the
value of seen when you get your results
at the end of the screen as I mentioned
a data flow bringing that micro RNA data
forward onto the system so that is
directly correlated with our analytical
results enable direct hit mapping we
didn't have to go back and paste the
data back in and try and map it back to
those micro RNA library information it
gives us traceability which is key
sometimes when you get an unexpected
results certainly when something happens
at the bench and I don't get the outcome
I'm expecting my first inclination is to
wonder what I've done wrong but when you
have the information all stored in the
dart database you can go back and make
sure that everything was done properly
and that the results are the legitimate
results and you may need to change your
way of thinking
as I mentioned gives you the confidence
that if you're going to go back for his
validation or you need to confirm any
data that you've stored previously you
have the confidence to know that you're
going back to the correct micro RNA in
your library and that's what ever hits
you identify whatever hits hold up
should be not have introduced any errors
in the process and although we didn't
use it for this screen as we touched on
earlier the bringing that data forward
can enable data driven pipetting for
example at the end of our screen all we
had left were basically dead cells but
if this were a different screen where
you were looking for a single clone that
was highly expressing a protein of
interest such as an IgG if your reader
data instead of dead cell counts was
instead you analyzer read that
information could then be sent back to
the system and that could enable the
automation to bring forward clones of a
above a certain threshold and those
clones would then be expanded for
further culture on a system that's a
great a great point Mike there's very
seldom do these assays assays give run
in isolation there's almost always
something upstream or something
downstream and after this essay is done
the results then feed into the next into
the next run and whether it's in your
group or maybe another group that
information unusually it's transmitted
so having all that information available
and an easy to export format pays a lot
of dividends to begin wrapping up here
if you if we look at good data design
requirements well our discussion today
really has been about looking at our
three different levels of information
with our our run our lab or norwell data
we looked at the sam EE acts the dart
and sammie process management data beta
manipulation tools and then we finally
looked at our data workflow with
importing processing and analyzing data
so as you're looking to build a system a
good data management plan needs to do a
few things and this is really this is
valuable information when you're looking
to plan out how to use use data in a
laboratory setting so you need to make
sure that you're identifying your
compounds or samples there needs to be
some sort of identity
it needs to drive experiment behavior if
you have information about what hits to
have or what concentrations to pipette
that needs to automate the liquid
handler or other automation in the lab
information needs to follow the sample
one pipetted the best way to correlate
information is to is to move it forward
so as you move off of your library plate
into your ass a plate or if you do
serial dilutions or replicate plates
make sure that those identities are
moved forward into those subsequent
pieces of lab where so that when you do
get information the same plate that has
the read value also has the identity
that you're trying to track that makes
your analysis much easier because things
are already correlated a good system is
going to capture information generated
during the process if you're the one
that's copying and pasting results out
of one excel spreadsheet from the MD
reader and pasting it into another excel
spreadsheet that has your your plate
mapping then you are the data manager
with the Sami system we pull that
information directly out of the minimax
reader associate that on on the plate
and then we can perform that correlation
through dart and in Excel you need to be
able to correlate information that the
ID and the results need to be side by
side and then anything that you have
learned in the screen weather was
produced in a report or not needs to be
retained it needs to be something that
you've captured and can come back to
there might be some additional insight
that is you return to this information
you can extract some sort of additional
conclusion from information that you
already have that's where data tracker
can really be valuable so in successful
experiments recognize workflows identify
two data flows and you want to make sure
that when you're choosing equipment you
also have software that drives it that
can be driven by data that implements
these data workflows and provides
reports with the information you need
and stores data from every sample every
time that it moves so with that we just
like to thank the
the folks at beckman coulter and also
our colleagues had molecular devices for
the assistance that they gave us the
integrated solutions group for helping
us set up the cell culture system and
there's the group and molecular devices
for working with us on the I 3x with
minimax and with that we conclude and
thank you for your attention our happy
to take questions at this point well
thank you so very much Mike and tin for
your wonderful presentation but also
like to remind the audience in regards
to how to submit some questions by
selecting on the Greek you a question
tab all right we do have a couple of
questions that we do have for today our
first question is when making a data
management plan should my IT group be
involved and how does this interact with
my existing limb system that's a great
question and I've worked with customer
accounts who have both types of scenario
sometimes you have I have talked to some
some customers and they say my IT group
is so busy they're really helpful but
they just can't get to me and so I need
to kind of manage my data myself and so
we have tools with we target a
laboratory where you're not going to get
a lot of assistance from your IT group
now on the flip side we love to work
with company IT folks because they can
make these tools even more powerful so
we have hooks in there to copy
information out of limb systems and
attach it into our biomech or sammy
software likewise on a reporting side we
have ways that the lymph system can
automatically extract the result data
the same information you're seeing in
Excel is available for another database
to extract automatically so really we
work either way and if you have access
to a good IT group count your blessings
because not everybody does and it's
wonderful if you have that and if you
don't we can work with you to when we
can give you some better
self-sufficiency well thank you so very
mention our next question is what did
you mean by talking about pipetting data
with sample and don't you and then you
don't actually pipette data do you
yeah that's that's maybe me taking a
little bit of liberty here being being
figurative but when when the biomech
pipetter puts tips down into a
microplate and we aspirate sample the
software behind the scenes is going to
look at the well data that is present on
that plate and then we have the
different layers of data that are there
each have a property called pipe edible
and if pipe pipe edible beta is set to
true then the software in this case
virtually copies that information into
the tip and then any place where that
sample is transferred then that data is
also attached to the destination well so
in case of well a one having sample ID
ABC 123 let's say we transfer that to an
assay plate and it also goes into well a
one and then maybe we Cyril the loot and
it goes into b1 c1 and d1 in this case
a1 b1 c1 and d1 of the destination plate
will all have the the identity ABC 123
and any data that gets produced there
will be attached back to that sample of
origin and the ID copies along with it
so it's figurative but I guess the point
that is important to me and what we've
worked hard to do is that the person
writing the method does not need to
write a sequel query or do anything
specific to copy that information it
happens as a side effect of the liquid
transfer thank you so very much and our
next question from the audience is I
spend a lot of time working with CSV
files in Excel can you describe how your
software can make my job easier yeah we
we've worked part of the reason we
wanted to do this webinar was to push
out some best practice approaches what
we feel are some effective ways of
managing data in the lab and you will
never get away from csv files in the way
that laboratories
structure today but you can use them a
lot less so the way our software works
is that you would browse to an input
file that you would be using today that
identifies the library we're working
with today or the samples that are being
processed maybe they're being mailed in
maybe they're being fed over to you from
another group but however those in that
information is brought to you you'll
start with the plate or within rack of
tubes and you'll start with some sort of
input file that gives you information
about them and so will attach that in
the beginning and that's why we talked
about the identity portion of the data
workflow it's at the start of the
process you attach it once now as you
drive through the automated system it
will copy that information if you're
moving the sample or maybe you're using
information that's attached to the
sample to perform some sort of pipetting
operation it could be a threshold and if
if the OD values above your threshold
target then only those wells get copied
and so it the automation behaves
differently every day because the OD
values are different every day but it
automatically selects the ones above
your target threshold it also could be
something like normalization where
you're using concentration information
to drive a volume that's being
transferred into a destination plate but
the idea is that you would use that CSV
file attached in at the beginning and
then you don't have to deal with
information no copying and pasting until
you're back in excel at the end and that
excel file is being produced as a dart
report but that's kind of the gold
standard that's what we would encourage
you to strive for and I think that we've
done a good job of removing any of the
intermediate CSV files from this type of
processing I thank you so very much it
looks like we have time for another
question here and how have these tools
truly driven ease of managing screening
workflows in the lab like I've been
talking a lot do you want to want to
jump on that one sure I think again a
lot of it goes back to what Tim's been
describing I
just the just bring you up from having
to worry about the data aspects of
during the actual screening itself as
Tim mentioned we did have an initial CSV
file that came from Sigma and that was
the last time I dealt with Excel until I
had all of my information at the end of
the screen being able to just kind of
automate that in the background without
having to necessarily set up additional
steps or additional queries etc really
enables you to just focus on obviously
the liquid handling aspects the part we
all think about inherently with
automation but then also whether it's
your experimental design or your data
analysis it just frees you up from
having to worry about the intermediary
steps and allows you to just focus more
on the science behind the screens well
thank you so very much and also like to
thank the audience for all their
questions Mike and Tim do you guys have
any final comments for today I really
enjoyed doing this webinar I'm glad we
had had folks that we couldn't see on
the other end but Mike thank you for
working with me today that was really
awesome I was my pleasure and again it's
a it's great to be able to have these
tools to use during the screens and so
thanks to you and the integrated
solutions group for making my life
easier all right we'll have that have a
successful time automating Iran's label
thank you very much gentlemen I also
like to thank our sponsors beckman
coulter this webcast can be viewed on
the man through September of 2017 lab
roots will alert you via email when this
webcast is available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who have made miss to
the live event until next time goodbye